neulich hängen wo bist du alter rocker
sports dürfen nicht benutzt werden
kriegen die eigene stadt dürfen die wir
nutzen werden auch ich muss die regeln
studieren ja ich meine lieben freund und
herzlich willkommen zurück zu einer
weiteren folge minecraft exit auf dem
hörster wenn man noch zusammen mit den
ja ich habe mir überlegt was habe ich
gerade eben in der letzten folge gesehen
dass ich hier noch sehr sehr viele ärzte
habe die noch nicht verarbeitet sind
diese möchte ich gerne in dieser folge
alle im zu ärzten schmelzen nebenbei
werde ich im conny zeigen wie das ganze
denn funktioniert und natürlich werde
ich an der kantine essensausgabe weiter
arbeiten und was hast du sofort
ich werde in dieser folge anfangen mein
haus ein bisschen zu bauen und zwar hab
ich da noch keine richtigen ideen
sondern nur so ein paar gedankens
anschieber den rest macht jetzt
eigentlich immer eigentlich spontan und
danach werde ich mich darum kümmern dass
wir die bäume so ein bisschen hinkriegen
da fertig und dann werde ich auch
probieren das mal mein aluminium zu
schmelzen und eventuell meine ersten
extra herzen machen erst extra herzen
das war auch bitter nötig haben alle ja
ich nicht ich habe eine andere
möglichkeit gefunden magst du nochmal
gucken
für was jetzt also bist du in der nähe
oder nicht ich bin gerade an meinem haus
ja weil ich habe jetzt geschaut
vielleicht funktioniert ja mit diesen
blöcken wird gerne dass du auch paar mal
den schalter betätigt also ich noch mal
kommen ja bitte lass das mal an der
schmiede noch ein bisschen mehr
verstecken diese redstone verkabelung ja
genau das wollte ich auch noch mal was
soll automatisch werden dass man
einstellen kann ob er jetzt die
investoren nicht und zwar am besten auch
hier oben warten und nicht denen da
unten weil ich habe jetzt andere blöcke
benutzen der hand so klein gemacht
vielleicht
ist das wohl besser dass die atoss
anlass also fallen jetzt hinten geworfen
in chaco also halb nach vorne wenn man
direkt daneben steht hilft er nach vorne
wenn man direkt darstellen
nach hinten sonst wird er nach hinten
wirft dann erhält er ich war kaka drehen
hat doch mal das komplette um den das
liegt daran weil wir sozusagen in der
iss unkontrollierter blog wenn ich jetzt
zum beispiel ein weiter hier baue so
cooks siehst du die und minimal
unterschied weil der nicht mehr diesen
blog hier blockiert glaube ich dass es
so funktionieren kann
du wirst das fleisch dann gespannt
funktioniert perfekt 0 1 hinten
sonst notfalls kann ich ja hinten falls
er nach hinten wird ich kann ja so ne
mauer machen und dann da und sohn hopper
hin dass wenn er fällt also wieder
eingesammelt wird das kannst du auch mal
stimmt ja das ist cool deutschland was
andere ist weil ich habe noch eine idee
ich mag es hier eben den weg durch da
ich habe mir gedacht wenn ich meine
ausbau oder sein dass nicht so groß sein
sondern dann mach ich dazwischen einfach
sonne oder nicht ein weg ich glaube ich
mache da zwischen den kleinen fluss da
wär schön du richtiger zen garten ein
kleiner fluss so wie in gta diese
kleinen ganzen da immer so jetzt habe
ich so nah prozentig gefixt
aber ich weiß nicht ob gut aussieht das
ist die frage ich komme eben ganz vorbei
einfach und zwar habe ich jetzt das so
gebaut war das lag auch daran weil der
block den ich darüber als cover gesetzt
habe der hat ja auch irgendwo die den
blog blog einträge in sein höher gesetzt
habe
passt schon und jeder kann man auch
nicht super springer ist heißt das läuft
ja sollte laufen durch ihr leben auf so
einer
hast du ja genau das hätten der
blockwarte den kann man auch bei uns
hast du mit cover bekommt
merci seccua es lebt war perfekt ja
sieht sogar geil aus eigentlich kann man
die treffen in der mitte findest du gut
ja klar sich aus wien war zumindest
dahinter genau das kann die man ich hab
ja sogar wirtschaftsbau natürlich auch
dann macht das einfach leben
wie soll heißen mit coolen namen etwas
neues feature ja das ist ein guter name
so wirklich so heißen
wir müssen uns gegen sind was ist wenn
so ein typischer typ der hinter der ba
sitzt ohne witz ich bin der experte
dafür partner lieber eine aufnahme
einfach mal im internet zu surfen hat
mir letztes mal schon typischer ja denn
ich will dann packt jetzt wahrnahmen und
heraus kommt direkt rein finden obwohl
diese wochenendlichen metzger namen also
keine ahnung so handelt oder so richtig
deutschen namen so nicht kevin de weert
er ist glaube ich wohl erst mal gesagt
ich weiß was gewinnen ist aber so
gerhard das ist doch genauso wie gut tun
hannelore perfekt die kantine hannelore
hannelore kraft oder willst du handel
oder kraft so nenne ich die tiere nahm
sie an der lore kraft weil sie mob falle
an und jetzt wird gleich bei
erfahrungspunkte und analog ab geboren
werden kann und stets ab hannelore kraft
kommt hinter dem tresen der selbst ein
bisschen arsch aufreißen fürs land
so ich mache jetzt in flüssen glaube ich
ich glaube wenn ich es mit marvel
unterläge sieht das ganz in ordnung aus
jetzt bricht nur ein bisschen was was du
geil das wird zwar abwechselnd produktiv
sind weil man wenn ich an meine
aufnehmen oder irgendwo anders
dann mache ich irgendwie nichts in
unserer stadt das bei mir auch mal der
fall
man hätte ich mit leuten aus der stadt
aufnehmen bin ich mache ich die
produktiv ist mir aufgefallen so anderen
städten mit leuten aus unserer stadt so
als nähme dann bin ich irgendwie
produktiv ich hole mir wasserwacht
bisschen oder ist zeigen wie die
allerdings funktioniert die spiele ja
ich trainer in wassereimer dann kam ich
hab ich hier nicht noch wasser wo hab
ich denn da war aber noch genug
das heißt wir bringen hier erst mal gold
gremmel online wer bereitet alles vor
er muss auch nicht wird die farm ist so
automatisiert uns gar nichts wissen
außer dass alle rein zu tun
aber du musst auch mit lava nach für
nach kann ich ihnen gleich taten vor
habe ich dir meine eine alte frage ist
ist das hier jetzt genug für handel oder
braucht die irgendwas oder ist die so
zufrieden hier hab ich keine heimat bist
du zufrieden ich glaube die mark und
auch hier mit der farm auf jeden fall
ist richtig verknallt und also das ist
gut das brauche ich extra so weil hier
abgesehen konnte hier so hoch jumpen an
der kante und das soll so nicht der fall
sein das heißt wir noch zwei covers
genau das heißt einmal so und einmal so
dann sind alle froh ich würde schon
wieso es anfängt zu legen
gerade die mob falle angemacht joker
auch wenn ich so in die richtung gucke
ja was heißt ich mache jetzt noch außer
ich brauche nur einige ich lege mich hin
ausgemacht und jetzt wird getötet
bingo
sehr schön die malediven erfüllt dass
der zweck oder nicht ich finde auch cool
alle saudis übels und produktiver ich
sag mal so die anderen mussten lassen
cent verlegen weil sie uns den server
gequetscht haben und wieso für den
normalen gebrauch eigentlich folge
wollten wir zeigen genau aber irgendwer
hat mein links tag kaputt gemacht hier
warte ein anderer funktion sie halt was
passiert es läuft nicht mehr
das ist passiert weil sagt genau was
passiert es sind ja keine sache mehr
drin gewesen auf einmal jetzt zwar
irgendwie hängengeblieben
jetzt weiß ich auch was hängen geblieben
ist hat mich jemand kaputt gemacht es
gab eine server restart du hast du hast
langsam mit kabel hab genau weil es ganz
hart angeht direktschaltung immer kaputt
das ist immer so ich habe auch noch von
dir eingesammelt und so haben wir haben
da ich meinen keiner fortune ausgepackt
habe jetzt kann ich dir zeigen wie das
geht ich sitze nur kurz einmal den
leuten eine ganze sache kommen auch hier
raus bleibt nicht alles unter wasser
hier wunderbar und zwar du muss darauf
achten dass du viel arbeit im hass ich
habe hier zwei kanister drin
das heißt eigentlich ist das umfangreich
war du hast ich hab ja schon alles was
du brauchst hier drin das heißt hier ist
diese in schale
hallo genau weg denn da genau hier ist
diese in schale und du musst du gucken
das klug ist als slave angezeigt sein
und ich sehe gerade das ist eine grafik
back denn da ist keine lava drin
das heißt muss dann einmal dass ich
jetzt hier wieder hier rein guckt in den
mietern da hab ich so gold travel oder
eingepackt du kannst ja alle alles was
du gremmel order center gibt es ja auch
oder ganz hereinkommen allein schon
genug und dann schmiegt sich das und
durch die reds und schaltung wird das
hat sowieso schon automatisch zu blocken
und kommt in die kiste und neun
automatisch das heißt ich muss noch ein
paar
eine ärzte hast du die mir schenkt bild
gerade mal ich hab ja da muss weg aus
dem kanister rechtsklick auf den
kanister genau du siehst dass du hoch
geht und jetzt wieder hier rein gucken
sollte das eigentlich gehen aber wieso
verwandelte das gold-triple auch nicht
ich weiß man als firma an und ist auch
in ordnung geht aber zum beispiel privat
sein
das heißt da siehst du das tat jetzt
notenbanken und das braucht etwas ist es
halt okay geht langsam hoch ja und das
gute daran ist es werden immer
verdoppelt heißt ich bin drin
ich bin model in soja das ist wieder
eine flüssigkeit so dass darstellen also
das ist ja noch fest aber das ja noch
gestopft werden muss
aber das wird noch eine flüssigkeit das
nicht auch dass das so heißen
flüssigkeit ist es dauert halt ein
bisschen und danach was zu schmelzen
dort auch noch ein bisschen knicks
pension ist raus auf welche art wir uns
geeinigt hannelore kraft alle leute mit
hna nlb so die politikerin
hallo kaftan lorig kraft heißt auch cup
hindern
hannelore kraft deswegen wieder auf eine
lore kraft war ihre kritiker denn hier
drin hallo gesagt dass am besten ist
denn jeder so sein text speck update
matthias und bild von der donner dabei
werde über drauf hält dann später sogar
hannelore kraft und jeder muss sich bei
ihr nicht mit einem knicks gedanken
seien knox jeder wenn jeder ein
schnitzel will muss man der knox machen
was ist ein sogenannter knopf ich glaube
ich mach das doch so dass das teil
automatisch im rüber geschickt werden
die teile oder findest du nicht du das
musst du gucken wie weniger aufwand ist
für dich jetzt weil ich will jetzt auch
nicht so viele opfer machen
beim elektro wenn man so ein bisschen
gerade sollte eigentlich dass die
schweine angelassen
sollte sie ausmachen also eigentlich
sollte die schweinefarm nicht lenken
weil die schweine werden ja direkt
getötet aber ich kann ja schon wie voll
der hobby ist das ist ja irgendwie
leistung
die kiste ist voll deswegen mit steaks
mit der oper auf ja ich hab immer ein
paar snacks rausgenommen selbst was zu
essen fahren ausmachen am schloss macht
fällig darum sind noch scheine aber okay
war dort nichts mehr
deswegen habe ich den schalter
angebracht genommen das machen wir nun
scheint das schon dass man erwarte ja
moment bin leichter hat wieso wir gehen
da nicht rein wie sticks aber ich hab's
aufgenommen
das eine glas müsste mir nur wiedergeben
so und zwar ist es ja so dass irgendwie
braucht das 4 ticks das heißt 1234
wenn ihr schweine so sind alleine bleibt
mir welche über ein zwei drei vier mal
drücken und dann ist alles gut dann geht
alles weiter
ok mache ich jetzt mein haus gehört
hatte sich die kombination gut aus oder
kommen lassen
ok ich weiß jetzt noch nicht wie wir
haben uns geeinigt wie hat eigentlich
eine twitter fragerunde machen wir aber
13 minuten dann der nächste folge mir
mal was wir machen wollten
twitter fragerunde nee ich meine wie war
das mit dem es machen wollen
willst du das immer manuell einladen
oder wie willst was man alter jetzt
irgendwas abgestützt fms ist ja
abgestützt jetzt kann ich was abgestürzt
weil sonst da denkst ich dachte das wäre
schon sagen dass jetzt genau willst du
das willst du diese teile manuell
einfüllen oder nein
das doch viel zu umständlich ja aber das
ding ist mit doppel ende besser ist
jetzt so hannelore damit sie daraus
lachen ja wenn du ein politiker name ist
wusste gar nicht dass die existiert als
ob nicht so die frage ist jetzt ja da
hab ich kann hier keine kassiert in
unserem land ich kann hier keine
schaltungen machen weil das ist keine
technik nokia kennen nicht ob eine kiste
voll ist oder so naja stimmt das ist gar
nicht erst mit dem der das eis ich
könnte zwar eine kiste machen wenn du da
warst rein tust und ein schalter
aktiviert das da so eine klappt das dann
darüber erfüllt aber ist das ist das
gleiche in grün als wenn sie das selber
rein to stop das da rein zu schauen die
kiste reichtums daran einfach
ich denke die ganzen sachen die stacks
die wir bisher an reichen erst mal für
eine woche für jedes mitglied ja ich
habe auch schon circa 20 40 6
rausgenommen
der deutsche richter sitzt ja klar
perfekter deal ich brauche aber
wirklichkeit er
zwar noch zweijährige ergibt einfach
zwei er ich denke wenn drei holten
ausgelegtes der gerberau drin aber gut
okay ich hab keine erde mehr alter ich
habe mir diamanten als erde so olli
polnische fast vorbei ja wieso fünf
minuten da folgt das kann doch gar nicht
sein das wollte eigentlich dass hier in
den untergrund verfrachten dass man das
automatisieren kann aber schwierig der
untergrund bis jetzt dem untergrund
anleihen in die erde dass das nicht
oberfläche ist aber auch gesagt ach in
den untergrund ach so ich dachte in den
untergrund ist verstehe ich hier sind
wer ist im untergrund wenn sie nicht was
ist dieses ominöse unter und wie wird
gestern zander weismachen wollen dass im
so genannten untergrund dort auch dass
der untergrund statt pink verbündet
seien
erst statt bin ich kenne stadt bingöl
technics stadt pink ist eine frage ich
habe alle mini um und ich habe aluminium
nugget wie kriege ich das denn jetzt
herr eingeschmolzen tja was hast du da
aluminium das leben ich muss zeigen sie
habt ihr hingeschmissen
das kenne ich nicht in aluminium nugget
aber ist wahrscheinlich sowie sowie gold
nagels das heißt du musst es einfach nur
das tun und offenbar kannst du das
einfach so ein schmelzen so wie es ist
ich weiß nicht wieder rauskommt oder
kommt was raus aber auch nur so rein wie
erzieherin geworfen ok darf ich dann
einmal ganz kurz alte schmiede nutzen
tut ja wie viele ärzte bildung ist okay
die ist wer weiß was aber jetzt weiß wie
es geht dass es ein klick niemand war
spitze nein weil das darf man nicht
vermischen man darf die ärzte niemals
mission weil sonst kommt irgendwie kacke
jetzt raus wirklich gar nichts raus
wirklich so märz genau so heißt das
genau na gut ihr könnt also kleiner
fluss bisschen traurig dass raffl war
wie so könnt ihr es nicht schmelzen
das zu machen was wird der strom weg
hier die nicht gerade mache eine
triumphfahrt triumphfahrt
aber ich habe alles mit fiat abwarten ob
jetzt eine spitzhacke mir besorgt die
fortune aber kein statt so also ich
werde mein haus dann wahrscheinlich
irgendwie hierhin baum und da wird das
mit einer garten hin kommen meine das
habe ich auch gesagt die erst habe ich
so abkommt klaus klaus richtig
unauffällig dann wie üblich stellen mein
inventare c voll wenn man spielen muss
ich will nichts haben ich stehe hier nur
per inventars eva jetzt erfahren haben
die weg quatsch ich gar keine erfahrung
die ein sammelheft ich hänge
wo bist du alt rockers dürfen nicht
benutzt einen krieg der eigenen stadt
dürfen die wir nutzen werden auch ich
muss die regeln studieren ja wisst wo
junge diese walkers vorträgen mich mega
auf du hast du keine angst geschenkt
ehrlich hast du ja es ging es nämlich
auch keinen bogen
was das ist es der jacko zu der
und ich will ist die folge beenden
müssen wir an wasserstoff you
ich hab die zuckerpuppe gegen stucki
sterben aber warum denn nicht sie doch
nichts getan
du hast angefangen anzugreifen nein
lacht okay ich schüttele chocobo bin ich
hin das ist so gelebt als schoko das ist
lila hallo sebastian block abgebaut habe
ich nicht was aus versehen rostock
eingestellt da wo er stand
nein da steht dann nicht doch nein
wurden steht ihr okay ja gut meine
lieben freunde das war es mit einer sehr
recht eigentlich über die produktiven
folgen oder auch der listung kaputt
produktiv und sonst würde ich sagen wenn
es euch gefallen hat lasst doch einfach
eine bewertung da das wird uns auf jeden
fall freuen
ok so sehr will ihn nicht liegt mit ins
bett ich kann online als lieben abgebaut
aus versehen